tout de suite place à notre décryptage
avec nos invités
avec nous pour en parler frédéric est né
lé directeur du service des urgences de
l'hôpital avicenne de bobigny et denis
millet co président de la fédération des
syndicats pharmaceutiques de france
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france alors c'est vrai le
président de la république il a annoncé
lors de son allocution mardi en plus
c'est vrai de la troisième dose dès le
15 décembre pour les plus de 65 ans
troisième dose de vaccin de nouveaux
traitements qui doivent arriver à la fin
de l'année en france il ya un antiviral
le module pirs à wihr qui est développé
par le laboratoire merck pilule qu'est
ce qu'on s'est concrètement sur cette
pilule d'abord qui est déjà utilisée aux
et au royaume uni et sur son efficacité
sur le co vie de frédéric à donner
écoutez c'est une molécule développée
par le laboratoire merck qui à l'origine
étaient les gènes molécules en fait
design et pour la grippe tiens
nucléosides c'est si vous voulez une
certaine nouveauté dans le traitement
pour le coc vite parce que c'est un
antiviral directe c'est-à-dire qui va
inhiber ou diminuer la réplication
virale du sein ce co2 en
substituant à nucléosides par ce
médicament et en trompant si vous voulez
la réplication virale ce qui est tout à
fait nouveau et c'est ce qui nous laisse
beaucoup d'espoir c'est d'abord un
médicament qui se croient par la bouche
donc très facilement transporter très
facilement
administrable par la bouche on n'a pas
besoin de perfusions intraveineuses on
n'a pas besoin d'hospitaliser le patient
mais aussi c'est le premier médicament
qui va voir une action directement
antiviral alors qu'actuellement nous
traitement efficace on soit préventif
soin à base d'anticorps monoclonaux donc
pour nous c'est au regard du communiqué
de presse un immense espoir qui doit
bien sûr être confirmée par les par les
articles et les publications
scientifiques qui vont pouvoir donner un
petit peu là hors bénéfice risque en
regardant un petit peu les effets
secondaires mais aussi les bénéfices
liés à ce médicament
alors il y a aussi d'autres traitements
qui ont été homologués le médicament
suisse le rhône après ve est un
médicament sud coréen le raid danby maps
pas facile à prononcer ces deux
traitements ont justement été approuvé
aujourd'hui même par l' agence
européenne des médicaments
on sait aussi que pfizer astrazeneca
développe aussi des traitements avant de
parler justement de ces traitements
précisément de leurs spécificités denis
millet on a l'impression quand même que
ça s'accélère
au niveau de l'arrivée de ces
médicaments anti qu'ovide est ce que
c'est votre sentiment aussi comment
l'expliquer on explique que ces deux ans
qu'on est né dans l'île la pandémie on
explique aussi parce que les médicaments
qui est déjà en préparation le
professeur viennent d'en parler et alors
on est très on est traître est plus qu
on était en train de discuter de la
manière dont c'est le maul des fidèles
qui ravirent va arriver sur le marché
je pense que l'inquiétude c'est qu'il ya
assez peu on a compté 50 mille doses
actuellement on détecte douze mille
nouveaux cas par jour en gros on a
quatre on a quatre jours de stocks donc
il faut il faut relativiser ces produits
sont récents il faut pas négliger les
gestes de prévention pour autant c'est
parce qu'on a un médicament qu'il faut
continuer à prendre le risque d'attraper
la maladie herman médicaments sont là
ils seront pas trois effets secondaires
on a très peu de recul on en a à un
salon jardin d'art n'a pas vu encore les
données qu'ils verront nous permettre de
savoir quel est le bénéfice risque donc
évidemment que c'est un espoir
supplémentaire c'est quelque chose de
bien ils arrivent ils étaient déjà sur
le marché c'est ce qu'on pourrait en
préparation pour d'autres maladies j'ai
très bien qu'ils arrivent mais attention
c'est pas pour autant qu'il faut se
relâcher alors justement expliqué nous
la différence entre le module pirs avis
requête un antiviral c'est ça et les
deux médicaments les deux traitements
que j'ai citées précédemment le rhône
après le raid 1 a minima qui sont des
dés de traitement par anticorps
monoclonaux
les clients je pense que je pense que le
professeur ne sera plus la même
de médicaments sincèrement aujourd'hui
par l'annoncé de la mort nous on
travaille sur le monolithe à dire depuis
quelques jours mais là j'en étais pas
encore ancrées les arrivées très
clairement
ce dernier cas venez
écouter le bol du pays d'arles et et
ravir c'était une molécule qui va
inhiber la réplique et la réplication du
virus satirique qui vont empêcher le
virus de se multiplier à l'inter de la
cellule alors que les anticorps
monoclonaux
c'est pas tout à fait nouveau ce sont
des anticorps qui vont s'ils voulaient
s'agripper à des halles à côté
design et pour
inhiber la comptine s et réagir un peu
notre corps réagit contre l'entrée de
ville c'est à dire on rajoute un
anticorps
parfaitement ciblées contre une protéine
du virus en espérant que ce virus soit
détruit grâce à ces anticorps le
problème c'est que ces anticorps
monoclonaux san luis en milieu
hospitalier par voie intraveineuse alors
que les deux médicaments a présenté par
le vent de la vente amer faïza sont des
antiviraux qui ont tout à fait un autre
mécanisme des antiviraux direct et qui
auront la vente de sa demie c'est par
voie orale
simplement des comprimés qu'on avale ya
une question sur le télégramme verte et
france qui s'affiche une question à
d'agnès le danois enfin c'est pas
vraiment une question c'est une
affirmation nous avons déjà des
traitements efficaces tels que
l'ivermectine est l'hes hydroxyethyl
rockin alors justement donné milliers
c'est vrai ce que vous pensez que ça va
relancer un peu la polémique sur les
traitements l' usage de ces médicaments
alors ça communique les forums par
contre je crois que maintenant enfin ce
débat a été tranché l'ivermectine est
ainsi que l on fait preuve de
suffisamment de d'efficacité et
d'innocuité pour andré et sinon on les
aurait utilisés franck il faut arrêter
avec ce débat en disant que
délaissé
d'ailleurs ce que c'est et produisent
des produits frelatés c'était très bien
non ces produits non ils n'ont pas
l'efficacité qu'on attendait ils ont un
certain nombre d'effets secondaires mais
ce ne sera pas sans effet secondaire
c'est certain mais en tout cas ils ont
fait fi qualité avec des études c'est
solide et démontrer ce qu'on avait sur
les remèdes les littoraux qui tu t'étais
j'ai très peu mettre la main peuple a
fait quoi et qui la peau qui est
nombreuse mais pour ne montrer leur
efficacité voilà je crois qu'il faut il
faut ce débat alors il y aura toujours
les rois ou quiproquos vide les fans et
pro hydro qui lie les produire mais qui
voit là je pense que ça va être très
difficile de porter un certain nombre de
gens de 7 de leurs certitudes maintenant
voilà on a fait un mort quatre
scientifiques et certifie quand ce qu'on
se base sur des études sérieuses qui
sont validées par pas par d'autres
scientifiques opaques et injustes et
mise d'un paddock qui avoue dans un coin
voilà ont été libérés at il été question
qui n'est pas efficace on peut pas
qu'aux
d'ailleurs de nuit est ce que on sait
qu'il ya cinquante mille doses on l'a
dit tout à l'heure de du médicament mot
nul peut ravir qui ont été commandées
par la france est ce que vous avez vous
des informations sur la
commercialisation la mise sur le marché
de ce traitement à votre niveau
travailler à la mise sur le marché
cette commande spécifique de deux dates
au nombre de deux deux services seront
autorisés à le prescrire ça va pas être
précis en vie de n'importe comment et
donc on aura des mêmes des modalités de
commandes auprès d'un intermédiaire côté
via kies approvisionnera très rapidement
souvent un ou deux jours on va voir le
produit le plus rapidement possible
effectivement il faut qu'il soit 2002 à
trois jours ci dans la détection du
virus il faut aller vite on entre à
mettre en place la technologie pour
l'avoir le plus aussi en train de
s'entre a-data gauthier s'était fait
jour si république
professeur adeler justement l'agencé
européenne du médicament doit et la
haute autorité de santé doivent encore
donner leur aval pour justement autorisé
le visage du mono le pire à vire
en france en tout cas dans une grande
partie de l'europe est ce que ce sera
avant la fin de l'année vous pensez à
qui va s'adresser aussi les 50000 pilule
doses en tout cas qui ont été commandés
laurent priverait alors il est vrai
à se mettre sous la dent que le
communiqué de presse de la marque hummer
qui est celui de freezer kursaal pour sa
pilule le dossier
aux autorités sanitaires je fais
remarquer que en angleterre il a déjà
abouti à une autorisation de mise sur le
marché pour le mot libye a bien
après
il faut qu'ils fassent rien la preuve de
son efficacité qu'il balance bénéfice
risque favorable pour semer est mort
pour confirmer les espoirs qu'on est
dans ce médicament mais point sensible
et on n'a même pas la publication
scientifique qui nous permet de poser si
vous voulez les effets secondaires
versus les effets bénéfiques de ce
médicament en tout cas ce qu'il a montré
aussi diminué de 50% le taux
d'hospitalisation et ou de décès dans
une population de patients qui étaient
affectés par le copil 19 qui avait un
facteur de risque pour développer une
forme grave s'ils étaient administrées
dans les trois à cinq jours après le
début des symptômes
donc ton qui viennent il doit être
indiquée ça sera des personnes à risque
je pense aux patients âgés aux patients
qui ont une comorbidité en tout début
des premiers symptômes à condition que
la paix sierre est affirmé qu'
effectivement son patient sont infectés
par commune 19 une autre question
télégramme à de mathieu les traitements
sont la solution depuis le début mais ça
ne rapporte pas assez un vaccin tous les
six mois pour le même résultat c'est
idéal financièrement sur l'aspect
financier justement de limoux y est c
les traitements c'est vrai
rapporte moins coûte plus cher peut-être
il coûte beaucoup plus cher là vous
l'avez évoqué on parle depuis
containers milliers d'euros oui 5
mettons sous presse en parle de 1000
euros par traitement 50000 euros mois on
était aux 50 millions d'euros voyage
attention ces échelles qui sont très
importants les vaccins c'est entre une
quinzaine de roms et où 15 à 20 europa
où le roi des 30 euros avec injection
avec tout doute le tout la technologie
qui photos collages et peut-être la
population mais là on est sur des
traitements qui sont par le millier
d'euros pour
les tops sont là les laboratoires auront
j'ai toujours le discrédit sur le
moratoire ils sont là pour gagner de
l'argent mais ils sont là pour faire des
produits efficaces et qu'ils sont
surveillés et le box sera donné raison
il faudra qu'on vérifie avec les études
que les populations suffisamment la
valeur ce petit édifice crise
suffisamment valable puisque m remarquez
les anglais l'ont fait je pense qu'ils
n'ont pas fait de manière
il en fait des raisons le cil ont mis ce
marché c'est qu'ils ont peut étudier les
dossiers qui s'appuie sur un solide je
pense qu'on arrivera au team à suivre ce
qu'on aimerait bien les voir c'est pas
un peu de données qu'on a pas on a
commis là laboratoire un peu juste pour
se prononcer on aimerait bien voir le
dossier scientifique pourquoi l'étude
est de plus près ch ça va arriver timide
sur le marché c'est que je rappelle que
c'est efficace
professeur anne est ce que ces
traitements finalement médicamenteux
sont représente une alternative
aux vaccins finalement et ça peut aussi
peut-être calmer les antilles vague
d'eau pensées
sont pas
communiqués de presse et on a quand une
véritable analyse scientifique de
l'efficacite médicament n'a aucun recul
quant à leurs effets indésirables ou
leurs effets secondaires donc il est
encore beaucoup trop tôt pour que vous
dire que ces médicaments pourraient
remplacer le vin on est dans deux
stratégies différentes
la vaccination c'est un traitement
préventif et ici on nous propose des
médicaments qui sont un traitement
curatif donc ces deux approches sont
complémentaires et l'une va pas empêcher
l'autre par d'autres s'il s'avère que
les traitements curatifs sont
extrêmement efficaces évidemment il
faudra
réanalyser notre politique de signal
mais il ya aussi et vous l'avez signalé
un problème de coût entre un vaccin qui
coûte quelques dizaines d'euros et les
une pilule qui coûterait plusieurs
milliers d'euros donc là aussi il y à il
ya amène dans la balance bénéfice risque
le cours de ces traitements donc je
pense que on va pas tirer des plans sur
la comète on est encore vraiment dans un
stade très précoce pour l'analyse de ces
traitements antiviraux curatif mais pour
nos cliniciens c'est un immense espoir
parce que qu'on voit encore à l'heure
actuelle des gens mourir de lakovic 19
et on aimerait bien avoir des
médicaments qui pourrait arrêter ce déni
mais du coup très rapidement ce n'est
pas un peu rapide de la mise sur le
marché la des traitements dont on vient
de parler vu le peu d'informations dont
on dispose de milieux très rapidement
ce que on l'a bien dit pour l'instant
ils sont pas mis sur le marché n'ont pas
l'autorisation de même ordre que pour le
meut les pires à vire on attend il
attend une autorisation en angleterre on
attend qu'ils osent autorisation en
europe on voit le valider en france une
fois que ces messieurs marché c'est
parce qu'il aura fait une offre une
efficacité après il faut relativiser les
vaccins on sait qu'elle est négatif sur
les mentalités de l'ordre départ 6 90%
un peu moins depuis le nouveau variant
mais là on ne parle que de 50 pourtant
portions faut que le pari est grave pour
les gens te dire je ne va-t-il pas parce
que jamais jamais le cas du protège
d'une fois sur deux le risque est
important comme je pense qu'il vaut
mieux se vacciner avec un avec une
protection aller même si on était 80 %
ensuite il malgré ce vaccin auront là on
aura une deuxième une deuxième chance
mais avec le traitement mais ne ne pas
ne pas qu'il est envisagé le traitement
qui arrive derrière on a un très gros
risque notamment pour les personnes à
risque merci à faut donner me et co
président de la fédération des syndicats
pharmaceutiques de france et merci à
vous professeur fabrican et directeur du
service des urgences de l'hôpital
avicenne de bobigny